but here's the show i take like you you
say these stories about bernie sanders
i'm like yeah well that's why i liked
him
liked past tense and then when he
basically you know got his knee and
kissed hillary clinton's pinky ring i'm
like this guy's got no principles i
don't care what he's fighting for he
could have absolutely said i'm not going
to endorse her sorry have a nice day and
that's that's it but instead he was like
whatever the machine needs of me
and now what is he doing i mean this is
a guy who in in 2016 cycles in 2015 said
that open borders is a koch brothers
proposal to you know to exploit these
workers and things like that
and then come to the you know 2020 the
2019 primaries and all that stuff he's
talking about open borders and free free
medical care for non-citizens and stuff
he totally flipped on all his positions
you know that's what i see when i see
like the squad aoc man i remember as
soon as she got elected all of a sudden
her stance on palestine and israel
started shifting activists started
getting really angry like what's going
on why is why is she walking this back
she needs to because she didn't know she
was talking about right so they get in
and they just say tell me where the line
is and i will tell it
look i think part of this is that
you know we think about these members of
congress as like what they're doing in
congress with legislation hearings
briefings investigations so on and so
forth but i think this newer breed of
members of congress and there's people
on the right who are this way as well i
think they see a lot of their
constituency the same way as like an
instagram influencer or like a celebrity
sees their constituency right like as
long as they're making a lot of progress
in terms of the retweets the likes the
shares the subscribers um they're
raising a heck of a lot of money i think
aoc is one of the best fundraisers in
congress because of all our small donor
base and their support i think they see
themselves as achieving some level of
success right and maybe they will even
achieve long-term political success in
their careers by doing it um but it
isn't necessarily the most effective or
the best way to move things in congress
i mean i'll give you an example i think
that you know rashida talib or ilhan
omar
you know they they they get in a lot of
hot water talking about israel in the
middle east
um but what exactly have they
accomplished on those issues like i
can't think of i can't think of them
they aren't any of the authors of any of
the primary legislation on middle east
human rights issues that's betty
mccollum or some other members of
congress when there was a recent
outbreak of fighting between israel and
gaza it was john ossoff it was a very
kind of low-key senator from georgia who
organized the letter calling for a
ceasefire it wasn't ilha tomorrow or she
had to leave
sometimes being the more like outspoken
twitter punchy type person you know
maybe it'll get your applause your fan
base to make you a little bit of a
celebrity but it isn't necessarily the
way to actually move things in congress
and actually carve out um
you know some progress and i think yeah
i mean to be fair to them i do think
that they they have sometimes
unrealistic expectations put on them i
mean their freshman members are calling
her so they're like you know some of
them are there have been there for two
terms now um normally when you're in
that position you're not going to be
that effective right just because of how
a house operates on the senate's very
different you can be very effective as a
first-term senator very very impactful
but the house is a little bit different
so some of the expectations are maybe a
little unfair on them but also at the
same time
you know i think of them more as
influencers and i think of them as
lawmakers because that's mostly what
they do i think uh i refer to this as
the aoc phenomenon how is it that she is
such an effective fundraiser
the way i describe it is imagine you
have a hundred cities
and in those cities
forty seven you know forty percent are
republican
42 percent are democrat and then you've
got a mix mishmash of libertarian and
green party and
unaffiliated whatever well i think those
numbers are probably unfair because
probably a lot it's like thirds is
probably independent voters but the
point is ignoring that let's say that
out of each city
one percent is
democratic socialist pro aoc
now if you're in that city and you're
trying to fundraise you're not going to
make any money because you're like you
know you got one person who can donate
to you
but what if you could tap into the power
of the internet and now you have every
major city across the country those in
each in each and every city where
there's just one person who believes
that you believe all of a sudden now
through the internet they're connected
to you and funneling money to you and
now all of a sudden aoc is raising money
outside of her district and it's a new
phenomenon they talk about the squad
members getting i think most of the
donations came from outside like the
substantial amount like 97 percent or
whatever came not from their own
districts so what they're doing is
they're they're taking the fringe of
each and every city
they're online speaking up sending money
to aoc aoc is not uh i would say she's
popular in the sense that all of those
people are loud now
but if we were to if if this was before
the internet era
she would not be considered popular i'd
imagine right you you have it's
interesting because an equivalent figure
if you go back to like the pre-social
media era would maybe be like dennis
kucinich right like kucinich was
probably the most left-wing member of
congress he was a democrat congressman
from ohio he ran for president a couple
times and basically the bernie platform
didn't really get anywhere
um but it's exactly that like kucinich's
power base was his actual district in
cleveland in ohio or like in cleveland
area at ohio uh he wasn't tapping into a
large sort of internet social media fan
base that maybe represented a small
sliver of america but could give him
tons and tons of money the same way that
i think really starting with ron paul
like ron paul on the right and the
libertarian side you know representing
sort of a minority faction of people but
he was able to mobilize a tremendous
number of internet donors some of which
transferred into volunteers which
increased his profile which actually
gave him a real platform and a voice in
the political debates and actually it
gave him some surprising performance in
those couple of primaries that he ran in
uh i remember the daily show had a
really fun segment about how like he got
maybe second in a state and like the
major media didn't even mention it but
like you know he he obviously was doing
very well punching well above his weight
you know ron paul started that and i
think bernie sanders continued it uh and
now you have people who i think i would
argue are much less
impactful than someone like bernie
sanders which is the squad um who carved
out their social media niches and yeah i
think they provide them with enough
money to basically fend off any kind of
challenger within their district which
would only come from within their party
because they're all very democratic
leaning districts
but that simply isn't the way that you
actually change things in congress the
fulcrum of congress is typically the
swing districts right it's the districts
that a party can't afford to lose yeah
and uh the ones that give them the
majority and the control of the
committees and the chairs
but which are always very competitive
because i don't think you can be aoc
talking about prison abolition i mean
that's the real thing she's talked about
and win any swing district anywhere in
america that would be turned into an
advertisement by the republicans and
you'd be gone and you know the next
cycle but you can sitting in a district
that i don't know if her district is
like d plus 30 or 40 or z plus 30. yeah
it's pretty it's pretty up there uh you
can say basically anything you want
right it'd be very hard for anyone to
defeat her incumbents very rarely lose
any kind of primary challenge and
particularly in that in that kind of
left wing of a district i mean nancy
pelosi said you could take this glass of
water put a d on it and it would win in
aoc's or my district
they know it how how broken is this
system right um you know we we we have
talked with other gop candidates in the
past who are in like deep blue areas
and i'll tell you man the only reason
areas are deep red or deep blue is
because
the the parties don't invest money
they're like what's the point and it's
like well dude if you're not trying to
influence people on your ideas you're
losing and i'll tell you it's mostly
phenomenon of the right they're they you
know we mentioned this before they don't
care about culture
they're sitting there thinking that
appointing federal judges is winning the
culture war and it's like no
because i'll tell you this
you can point out however many judges
you want but if amazon cnn cable tv new
york times all of these things are all
saying x is right and why is wrong the
courts are going to be like i'll just do
what what they tell me because you know
the the courts ultimately in the end are
just enforcing popular opinion we've had
we've had a bunch of changes of
precedent and and
over our you know several hundred years
free speech as we know it i think was
only
essentially not literally codified but
precedent was set what like 1968 i think
it was one example of this would be uh
school prayer right like people today a
lot of people you talk to them they're
like well school prayer's not allowed
because that's constitutional in the
establishment clause blah blah blah
school prayer was in schools until like
the 1950s or something right the courts
were defending it wasn't a matter of
just like the constitution being
rewritten it was just that the culture's
perception
of whether or not it's appropriate
changed right yep and that was much more
important than having a particular judge
on a particular court so as the right
you know these establishment neocon
republican types keep thinking that oh
we're going to just win in the institute
in the in the governmental policies
meaningless
meanwhile the left is controlling all
these institutions taking them over so
you know it is a good point you bring up
that uh
someone like aoc couldn't win in a swing
district i do think there's something
interesting to be said about the need
for republicans to go into an aoc type
district and actually start advocating
and presenting an alternative well let's
remember that um one of the
he he's obviously in a very different
role these days but one of the icons of
the republican party rudy giuliani was
only that icon because he was able to
win power in new york city yeah now
the republicans do have a nominee in new
york city curtis lewis who's a former
you know guardian angel
he's actually a very storied figure in
many ways but i you know i haven't
looked it up but i doubt republicans are
investing just about anything in that
race yeah and you know i to be fair to
them i doubt that they would win it no
matter what they invested but it's a
matter of long-term investment right
it's a matter of running a series of
competitive candidates until you get
someone like rudy giuliani who's
actually going to win who's going to
pave the way for someone like a michael
bloomberg who is you know
semi-republican um but if you if you
don't if you don't even try yeah
obviously you're going to end up with
that result i think this is what's
contributing to the culture war on the
hyper polarization in that republicans
and democrats are like i have no reason
to even talk to the people in these deep
districts and and now the hyper
polarization has gotten so extreme now
they're even more entrenched in not
communicating but if if you if you just
leave
new york city to get further and further
left without even trying
then we're drifting so far apart
eventually the ban snaps and then
there's just two different realities i
think we're already starting to see it
like portland announced they will cut
off trade and travel or whatever for
texas california banned state travel to
like a handful of states you're going to
have this phenomenon that we talked
about before where
truckers aren't going to go to new york
they're going to be like i can't go
there because i don't feel like dealing
with the uh you know the ban on public
accommodations for people who aren't
vaccinated let's say you live in texas
and you're a truck driver and they're
like hey we got a big shipment it's got
to be sent up to new york to be like nah
in texas they don't have the
restrictions in new york they do they're
in the back i don't feel like doing it
which is going to be interesting because
someone in new york is a trucker will be
like oh i can go to texas no problem so
it's creating kind of a one-way track
yeah i mean this is this is the
important thing to understand about
polarization so i actually worked on
polarization professionally from 2018 to
2020 i was i did a fellowship at a at a
center at berkeley called the greater
good science center which works on
psychology science
and so you know i spent a lot of time
talking to researchers who study it and
practitioners that work on it
here's the thing to understand about
it's not really based on what you
believe right it's not there there is a
really great political scientist at the
university of maryland liliana mesa and
who studied this and what she found was
that people who are most polarized from
each other are people who have very
strong political identities who very
strongly identify with the label like
liberal or conservative in fact they are
even more polarized from each other than
people who disagree more on like an
issue like guns or abortion or something
meaning you can be all the way to the
left but if you don't identify very
strongly as a leftist or a liberal it's
not a core part of your personal
identity
you probably aren't going to be as angry
or resentful or contemptuous of people
who are all the way on the right versus
even if you're somewhat in the middle
but you're like very strongly
identifying yourself as a democrat you
conceive of yourself as that way you can
be much much more polarized against
someone even someone who like agrees
with you on most of the issues but who
has the opposite political identity so i
think it's really about making that
political identity first and foremost
and then just not interacting very much
with people with other identities
because here's the reality i grew up in
the deep south as a very left-leaning
person particularly at that point i was
very left-wing compared to everyone
around me but you know all my friends
were republicans a lot of them hunted
you know you go to waffle house you see
someone with a confederate flag t-shirt
sitting next to someone with an mlk
t-shirt like that was the south growing
up in the 1990s there was so much mixing
and integrating and like old-fashioned
diversity of like you people would look
at you funny if you were like yeah i
don't want to have any friends or
republicans they'd think you were some
kind of freak or something right
but the facebook a vacation of the
united states where everyone has a kind
of curtailed personality and very strong
identity established through exclusively
in some cases politics
has made it much easier for people to
silo each other to segregate from each
other and again to elevate this part of
your identity versus all other parts of
your identity you know it's not your
hobbies it ain't your career it's not
your religion it's not your family life
it's
i in this house we believe xyz you know
you see those signs around northern
virginia you know you see you see i
don't know why they i don't know why
they're putting those signs up do i care
what you believe i don't really i don't
really want to give someone a political
litmus test upon meeting them but that's
what these people really can see with
themselves as it's tribalism i mean and
i'll tell you i think it's it's it's
look
republicans i think for the most part
are spineless feckless and aren't
fighting for anything i have very little
to say about
a party that's not doing much they're
not coming out and demanding the
department of gun services and a
repealing of the nfa and a gun in the
hand of every child you know as much as
i would jokingly be like yeah yeah by
all means they're not doing that
the democrats are absolutely
steamrolling pushing advocating very
hard for doing these things and then
when i call out the media for lying what
happens i mean look look at matt tybee
i'm sure you get it glenn greenwald gets
it you're all right wing now you're all
right-wing grifters simply for saying
hey media that wasn't true i think part
of it is that when somebody has a very
strong identity they viewed as an
identity threat to see someone disagree
with them right and i think one way to
respond to be the other yeah exactly one
way to resolve that threat is to
simplify the world and just say oh that
person's in the other in the other
category it's called um what is it
called
homogeneity
outgroup homogeneity bias right where
you think that everyone who disagrees
with you basically has one set of narrow
narrow beliefs that all of which you
hate and disagree with right and so yeah
it's i think it would be absurd if
someone were to look at my resume and
really honestly read my writing and
think that you know i'm a staunch right
winger or something they'll say it if i
went down to my uh state house in
virginia or something and told them what
i believe on criminal justice they'd
probably think i was like a lunatic
communist or something like you know but
what if i go on twitter and i say
something that like 60 of americans
agree with you know people will reply
saying i'm rudy giuliani or i'm a
fascist blah blah and it's just like
what are you talking about it's like
it's an it's an alternate reality right
my favorite is uh the satanic temple
they're suing over the abortion bill in
texas
and so i just sweet as like i want okay
so one of the tenets of the satanic
temple is that your body is inviable it
is yours and no one can you know mess
with it or whatever and i'm like
all right like what's your thoughts on
the new york vaccine mandate because i
agree with you completely and i i'm
pro-choice i've always been pro-choice i
have wonderful arguments with pro-lifers
and there's a sort of a libertarian
impasse we we come to and uh we go into
great detail explaining this 50 billion
times i don't know if i can do it again
but when i post something like you know
my body my choice i get these these
tribal leftists on twitter who will say
yeah but when it come to texas you
pro-lifers and i'm like i'm not pro-life
and they're like
well you're grifting them and then i'm
like i'm gifting to whom the left who is
in favor of the vax mandates by me
complaining about them or the right
who's pro-life and me saying i'm
pro-choice which who am i drifting to
you know it's really funny i think the
people who tell you that they always
assume that you are captive to somebody
else they never assumed that like let's
say if someone who's very right-wing
decide to have a conversation with you
that maybe you might convince them right
like it it actually does work both ways
but they assume it only goes one way
exactly so something i've often said is
politics flows in one direction
if there is a photo of
me
with a far left antifa guy they'll
accuse the aunt of a guy being right
wing
because it it but like me like i'm i'm
fairly independent centrist moderate
with some left-leaning policy some
right-leaning policies but if i'm
sitting next to someone on the right
they'll say ah that proves it tim's far
right if i stand with someone left like
whoa i didn't realize that antifa guy
was actually far right because it only
can go in one direction there's no
circumstance in which you take a
right-wing individual have him hang out
and crack beers with leftists and they
claim the right wing and right ringer is
a left winger which is wild because i
think that you know a lot of the recent
american history shows that
you know it's called contact hypo
intergroup contact or contact hypothesis
which is basically when people hang out
with each other you break down barriers
between each other so this is for the
most part been a huge win for the left
over the past 50 or 60 years of american
history right there's been much less
racial prejudice much less religious and
gender prejudice as a result of people
basically just mixing it up with each
other like that was you can talk about
all different ways techniques strategies
to make this happen but ultimately
there's people mixing up with each other
it was integrating right people just
getting to know each other being friends
has made america one of the most
tolerant places like on planet earth and
like in human history generally it's
worked out very well for left wing goals
i would say absolutely i agree thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you